thank you for coming to pie data global
2021 well we're here for
gus count guesses
talk and uh since this is time i'll hand
it off to him
thank you so much
sharing my screen for everybody so just
uh if you're here this is let me find
high performance python with numba i
think we're looks like we're about 45 to
50 minutes behind
so we're gonna we're in this break
period i'm gonna try to catch us back up
we're gonna go real real fast which is
fitting for high performance python and
so if you're if you're coming in for
storytelling with data we may just be a
little bit delayed um
so let's get into it so i have a couple
of quick slides and we're gonna go
really really fast so
uh the expectation for the absolute
beginner is that you may know about
python you've heard about it and if you
have that's good it's very popular this
is pi data i assume you've heard about
it
but you've heard some things about
python you're interested you want to
make it go fast let's get started so
let's jump in to our first example
because people will often say
that python can be slow
so i'm going to come over here into a
jupiter notebook
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
fake a scientific workload so we're
going to go apologies we're going to go
real fast throw your questions and other
things into the chat i'll try to monitor
as best i can
oh the other next talk is on uh zoom url
thank you so much for telling me that we
will go a little bit over then great
so
what we have here is a fake scientific
workload we're going to use
numpy and we're going to basically
pretend like we're gathering some image
data from some sort of detector from
some sort of sensor we're going to
smooth it so we'll average the input
points and we just have this this for
loop here that's kind of fortran style
it's basically this is some sort of
numeric kind of quantitative method
we're going to run this thing and at the
end of this we'll just pretend like
we're saving something so again this is
fake it's just meant to be illustrative
we're going to run this with numpy with
and with pure python oh let me refresh
right or let me
run this again and this is going to
execute in about 10 seconds and so we're
just looping through here running this
function gather from detector creating
this fake array we're doing some
smoothing
again just generic python stuff ah gosh
maybe it runs here processing five fake
images in about 10 seconds maybe that's
good enough maybe it's not but the
question is can we make this faster and
our first tool in the toolbox to do so
is we're going to introduce something
called number and number brings us a jit
compiler this means it's going to take
our python code it's going to compile it
we can now get closer to c
c plus plus 4 tran like speeds we'll
never exceed those but this is still
python and what's really nice about this
i'll go ahead and run this really
quickly while i talk about it what's
really nice about number and it's going
to be a very cursory explanation here
is that
this is a just-in-time compiler so if
you've heard about cython or if you've
looked at some things with c you need to
specify ahead of time what your types
are going to be with number we don't
have to do that because it's just in
time so i wrap this little decorator
this is one convention for using number
around my previous function i don't
change anything else of course also i
import number so i import number i wrap
this little decorator and now when i run
through those same five fake images and
process them
it runs much much faster so we went from
approximately 10 seconds to 700
milliseconds in fact
most of that was compilation time so
when i run this again it's even faster
now that the code has been compiled you
can see we're getting really low latency
so kind of first break right before we
even intro and get into other things hey
if you've got some if you've got some
for loops if you've got some
numpy arrays if you've got some things
where you might want to broadcast a
function across them
number is a really interesting tool to
check out because we can compile our
code we can get c c plus plus for trans
style performance we don't have to we
can do it very very simply for getting
started there's low penalty here for
getting things wrong now number isn't a
applied everywhere they're they're use
cases pro and pro and against
but just as a quick kind of carrot hey
check this out
this can be a really useful tool
with high performance we got to go
bigger right so we did five images to
continue this example let's do more
let's do 10x the number of images and
when we run this same thing we're gonna
as again these images are fake but meant
to be kind of a realistic example this
takes a little bit more time
four seconds and as we scale this up to
500 we'll see some linear scaling five
seconds to 18 seconds
so we're starting to hit a maybe a bit
more of a performance bottleneck on this
machine on my local machine here where
i'm running this jupyter notebook
so let me jump back
as an example here sorry let me go back
to my slides
so we went through this hey we took our
python code we and i'm sorry i got a
little bit discombobulated but our
number example took us from slower
python code to faster python code now
the reason i'm here the reason i want to
talk to you my name is gus kavanagh i
used to be a consultant i worked on some
data projects small and big i've got a
three week old kid so i'm a little bit a
little bit out of it um and what what is
i think what i like or why i'm here is
when i first got started working with
python working with data
i struggled uh with a lot of the tooling
that was around hey i want to analyze
some data i've learned a little bit
about let's say pandas but i'm
struggling to actually get this
installed get it get everything figured
out make it actually work and as an
example of this when i started my first
kind of python job
i didn't know what ssh was and so i
would walk to the server room there was
no cloud i'd walk this about 10 years
ago i would walk to a physical server
room i would pull the little rack
mounted appliance out and i would work
on that little appliance in the server
room no one else was in there i didn't
know any better and eventually i only
learned that i wasn't supposed to be
doing this my boss was like why aren't
you at your desk you don't have meetings
scheduled what's going on and i was like
i'm working on the server you know
they're like you need to understand you
need to be able to you can remote access
the server so this is when i say for the
absolute beginner now as i'm trying to
intro this talk
this is what i mean like i really i
understand there's this concept like
i've got some python i've got something
i can run locally but help me make this
work for me and show me all of the steps
in between don't leave anything out so
that's what we're going to do and so my
kind of expectation here uh hopefully
with that kind of quick number example
to to kind of what your whistle is
you are interested in pi data the pi
data stack is extremely popular that's
why we're here pandas numpy map plot
label includes psychic learn a bunch of
other packages
but they do struggle a little bit here
or i'm sorry why do we love why do we
like them they work they're easy most
importantly they are free but we're
going to hit some of these scaling
issues and we're going to hit some of
these speed issues so the fir that where
we want to what we want to introduce
next as we move into okay i've got a
pandas data frame the next big tool to
make this go faster is going to be
rapids so we're going to go back to our
notebook now and we'll explain what
rapids is
and how it works so i'm going to jump
over here for a second to a different
jupiter notebook
this one's actually running in sagemaker
and we'll go through all that a little
bit later but now i've got
my pandas data frame and i'm going to
read in this kind of canonical pseudo
big data data set this new york city
taxi data set everyone's probably super
sick of it we're going to go ahead and
read this in we're going to perform a
group by using pandas and this is going
to take about 20 seconds to run now
again that may be good that may be bad
but we can make this faster and with
rapids what makes rapids so interesting
and exciting is rapids is going to
extend the pi data stack
for the gpu so here i have i import
pandas with pandas convention as pd i
read csv i run a group by it takes 20
seconds or so
let's use a
part of the rapids package called qdf
i import qdf
i run qdf read csv
and i run a very similar identical group
by and this is going to execute much
much faster now oh
memory error how fun let's restart the
kernel
so this is this is supposed to be my
next example i've somehow gotten ahead
of myself
but let's run this one more time so we
restart this we'll execute our read csv
and so what we're doing and oh my gosh
i'm
[Laughter]
embarrassed
so
what i wanted to show you was this was
going to execute in about eight seconds
and the core idea being that
we'll come back over here very quickly
to some slides the core idea being that
thanks to rapids this package that came
from the good folks at nvidia we can
take our pandas code we can import qdf
and we can run very similar code we'll
also be able to do the same thing for
for numpy for scikit learn for other
packages but i want to show this this
pandas example with codif
however
what can happen and what will often
happen is you you can get these memory
errors uh specifically because the the
well for one reason because the gpu
memory can be slightly different than
the the cpu memory available on your
machine in my case on my sagemaker
instance
however what i was hoping to show was
that we would get this memory and memory
error with a larger data set
so in this case reading in the single
file this one has about seven million
records it's not that big at all
the gpu was going to be faster but
significantly faster
meaningfully faster worth the money
faster
questionable so in this case this will
definitely show a memory error when i
read in and forgive the ugly code but
when i read in the entire year's worth
of new york city taxi data which is a
larger data set
so 7 million times 12 84 million records
we hit this memory area error and this
is very common and so
this made me think of like me walking to
the server room like this is the kind of
thing where as a user i would get i get
stuck here
and there are ways of thinking about
how you should profile your code how you
should think about high performance code
you should absolutely read this book uh
by ian oswald and i won't uh pronounce
the other name i've read through the
chapter on number i clearly haven't read
the whole thing uh but this you this
will give you the actual like hey what's
the computer science approach to this
how can i do this really intelligently
what i'm trying to solve for here is
like i'm getting stuck with this
exception what do i do now and i really
want to stay with just within this basic
api don't make me think too much don't
make me understand too much
and so
what we're hitting at this point is
basically we've got enough data where
even though we have this really fast gpu
now we can do these
our compute is just
that's created a memory bottleneck so
let's go back uh to our slides really
quickly and basically what we've seen is
and this is you know does not scale gpus
will often lead to memory bottlenecks
very similar with pandas and in fact
with that data set reading in all 84
million rows on my my small sagemaker
instance that too would have caused
a memory error so
i i will will now say okay great we have
to scale to a larger data set we want to
use the gpu
how do we do this so we started with
i've got some python code i can use
number to compile it to accelerate it
i then went okay well i've got this
pandas data frame what's the best way to
accelerate that something like rapids
qdf runs on the gpu but now i'm stuck
because now it's not fitting in memory
i've got the i've got my compute running
fast but i'm stuck on memory and so if
we go to just a random person on twitter
i don't know this person you know but
from a couple weeks ago or from the late
summer asked what's the best way to read
a 100 gig file you know in the
twitterverse responded read the file in
chunks more ram you should download more
ram don't use python pray
you get lots of fun responses right and
somebody a very helpful a good samaritan
responded i'd recommend you use desk so
what is das what is this thing
das is a python package part of the pi
data stack that allows us to scale uh
arbitrary python code it has two levels
of api or two two basically interfaces
one is for data frames arrays cycle or
cell estimators and it will scale these
across multiple cores or across multiple
machines in a cluster this is going to
be very helpful for getting us around
our memory bottleneck we'll be able to
more efficiently use all of the cores on
a single machine while the memory on a
single machine or and in this case and
all of the nodes in a cluster which
we'll get to in a second
now desk also has a lower level
interface for more for arbitrary task
scheduling we won't cover that today
but you can do a lot you can build on
this a lot this is foundational for a
lot of other libraries
so
what often happens in twitter right you
make a suggestion you try to be helpful
someone's going to shoot you down so
this guy says no no you don't use das
you use pi spark and so as we're now
moving into the dash section of this
this is the the analog you'll see
outside of outside of the python world
is hey use spark use pi spark sure it
runs in the jbm but you have this python
interface das is very very similar as
this person points out it's also
distributed you and the idea here is
it's the familiar api you're going to be
very very close to the pandas api just
as pdf with rapids is very very close to
the pandas api so that we don't have to
learn something new which again comes
back to kind of my fundamental point of
or or motivation from starting this is
keep it please keep it as simple as
possible if i can run something in
pandas help me run this now faster help
me run this with more data okay uh not
just random people at twitter but real
companies organizations use this walmart
has a great example of using down here
at the bottom you can see some of the
logos rapids and dash together to do
in-store forecasts so they have to do
these 500 million forecasts all of these
combinations on year-long horizons it's
this monster problem this big simulation
and what they were able to do with
rapids with desk xu boost has a native
rapid integration it's able to reduce
this processing time down so they could
get it within a 12-hour window because
it has to be done every day so they
can't get it done in 12 hours it's no
good to them they're able to make this
work i have no idea how this is running
for them with all the supply chain woes
late sorry i won't comment this is a
little bit older than that but i think
it's a pretty like a good motivating
example so we've got kind of random
people on twitter saying hey das rapids
you've got companies like walmart hey
das rapids let's put it together and
jump through our example
and while i switch back here i'm just
going to check quickly in the chat
um
okay good so we got some questions about
how easy is it to get number set up
excellent
we will get to the setup here at the end
or not at the end but after showing this
next example with clusters of machines
so i'm going to switch from sagemaker
now over to google cloud platform
vertex ai but basically just a hosted
jupyter lab instance running all these
same examples in each environment
locally in the different clouds
and what i want to do now is i want to
install das
and i'm going to use cdf again and this
is that same code we ran before
and we ran this it took you know eight
or nine seconds but we want to run this
with everything and we ran with
everything we got a memory error so how
do we get around that well introduce
desk so their desk we can we will
install or we will import excuse me the
das distributed client as well as this
local cuda cluster in the interest of
time i'm not going to explain what this
is at the moment but i'm just going to
instantiate this i'm going to create
this local client
so what this is going to enable us to do
is more efficiently work with the
resources on my in this case client
machine which is this
gpu instance very modest gpu instance in
google cloud it has four cores 16 gigs
of ram and one t4 gpu and i can see that
right here in this local cuda cluster so
i've got my 14 gigs i've got my
i've got my gpu in here inside of it
should be here in this worker here's my
gpu worker tesla t4 which is like a good
combination of performance and cost this
instance i'm running costs something
like 38 cents an hour to run and i'm
paying for this so i want to keep the
cost down
and now i can go ahead and execute the
basically
not basically but very similar code
using das qdf to read csv and perform my
group by now in the interest of time i'm
not going to run this but i'll just show
you the wall time from calculated
earlier this now takes three minutes so
let's contrast with previously it was
hey we ran this group by or we were
trying to load all of the data even read
the data in we're getting memory errors
cuda errors hey you don't have enough
memory on your local machine or your
client
now we can execute this
so this is probably going to be another
good flag in the ground for a lot of
people here you pip install desk and
we'll get into the installation steps
it's relatively it's very
straightforward but you can use desk
locally on your machine on your local on
your your laptop workstation wherever
you are and you're gonna be able to get
around a lot of memory bottlenecks this
is especially useful for the gpu
workflows for using rapids for using das
qdf because it's more likely that you'll
run into those and with that you'll get
around it now three minutes isn't
necessarily barn burner fast time right
like i'm not we're not lighting it up at
three minutes and this is a pi data talk
i've got 30 minutes i want to be i want
this to be fun i want to be high
performance python so let me show you
some examples of using das now on a
distributed cluster so in this example
and i hope this is big enough i'm sorry
um in this in this previous example we
had das running on a local machine now
i'm going to have dash running on four
workers
and
i'm going to use a tool i'm going to use
a
piece of software called coil this is a
company i work for coiled i'm a sales
person for coiled so this is not a
coiled sales pitch it's just an easy way
of getting das clusters in the cloud
there are a bunch of other approaches
and i'll cover those at the end
but suffice to say once i have this
cluster with my workers on it let's just
make sure this is still up right i've
got a cluster 60 gigs of ram each of
these is composed of essentially my same
cpu client instance for
uh four virtual course 16 gigs of ram
uh now i instantiate my dash cluster
just as i did before
and when i execute this it's going to
run much much faster now note here or as
an aside i'm i'm jumping back from the
gpu i should have maybe been a bit more
explicit here i'm just using cpu workers
and i can come over here and take a look
at this and see what's going on so this
is a das dashboard this is available uh
regardless of how you deploy desk so
you're seeing it inside of the code
interface but this is the same if you
run it with a purely open source you'll
have this nice dashboard you'll be able
to see your task stream here all of
these tasks running
across the cores in each of your workers
and this will execute in about two
minutes or so so we're getting we're
getting improved speed up from our
single gpu from running desk on on the
single server from running our local
cuda cluster
but it's still not running as fast as
i'd like for a talk like this like we're
getting better we're getting performance
i could add more workers here i can now
start to linearly scale or i could solve
for this problem it's like how fast i
want this to run okay how many workers
do i need
i'm getting there but we want to see
what the gpus we want this to go even
faster so let's go get a gpu cluster
next and i'll kind of wrap up my code
examples here with the gpu cluster so
very similar again i'm going to use coil
but you could do this with a bunch of
other approaches and rapids does
document how to set all this up uh and
now with a gpu cluster i have four
workers each of them have the t4 gpu
which is so nice and now we can really
make this thing saying when we execute
this code this will execute about 13
seconds so let me run this jump over
hopefully it isn't finished by the time
i get there
because it's going really really fast
and you can see on the gpu this is going
to execute much much more quickly these
are those same tasks they're just flying
through
and in the desk dashboard there's a ton
we can do here to zoom in and try to
better understand we've got to zoom in
even further oh my goodness do we zoom
in on as to actually what is taking what
amount of time this is a whole kind of
talk in itself
but we'll be able to see and i should
zoom in further to show you exactly
which steps you can see the time here um
so
i want to pause there for a second and
i'll double and i'm going to take a
quick look at the chat um
but what we've shown is we've taken this
same uh workflow we started with
running on
running on our local machine or running
locally using pandas we hit it we
realized we we hit a memory error same
thing we used our our wrap our gpu gosh
the gpu's so fast but to get the full
data set we needed we needed to get
around a local memory bottleneck
installing desk and running desk excuse
me not there running desk on a
local das cluster helped us get around
this it was a little bit slower than
maybe i personally would have liked but
i solved this i'm now using rapids i'm
using a gpu i'm doing it with a
pandas-like data frame this is very
similar syntax read csv group buy i
don't have to learn a new api and then
i'm able to process this data i'm able
to get a big performance speed up
this is very very exciting for me i like
this this is probably where you could
stop if you want additional performance
you want to go even faster you can
distribute this out exact same syntax
with desk onto a cluster we could do
this on a cpu cluster and it ran in
about a minute 30 a minute 20 very
similar code read the csv group by and
we could go even faster on a gpu cluster
and again the code the important thing
here is our code doesn't change whether
it's local cluster or distributed it's
the exact same thing it's just this dash
code das pdf read csv
so if you if you haven't checked out
like benz lightlyn's talk or all the
stuff that the nvidia folks have been
doing here you really should but
hopefully this is like motivating enough
hey i can use a little bit of number to
compile some compile my python
especially for loops numpy stuff
broadcast functions do that if you have
data frames
you really want to look at rapids qdf
and you can use das distribute that
across clusters
let's talk a little bit now about how
this all gets installed and how all this
gets set up
so i will show that
here and i'm going to try to wrap this
up maybe i guess since i have an extra
minute or two i'm going to wrap this up
in the next five minutes
so
real quick on setup is uh and i'll just
show it directly from the different
cloud tools to use rapids they have this
this wonderful guide and they'll explain
where you can get things and how to set
things up in the cloud uh and this isn't
specific to the company i work for
anything like that it's just for aws
azure gcp
but what i've found to be the easiest
approach per cloud is to use their
hosted ml service so if you go into
sagemaker you can create notebook
instances and jump directly into jupiter
lab and here i just created a g4 dnxl so
this is about 75 cents an hour it's four
cores one t4
i don't have i don't pay for a very
expensive instance here because i'm
going to use something else coiled to
scale out when i need clusters of gpu
workers or clusters of cpu workers this
helps me keep my costs down
but in this case i create this notebook
instance
and then when i'm inside of jupyter lab
here it's very easy to get everything
installed because rapids gives us this
quick start which is is really really
impressive so i click over here on get
started
and they give you this little release
guide and so this is exactly what i
follow and you can choose between what
version you want what version of python
what version of cuda and what's nice
about sagemaker here in this case is
they give us all the things that we need
so if you try to install this yourself
which you could if you had a local gpu
but you'll need to install cuda this
comes pre-installed you just don't have
to worry about it so intentionally like
not giving details here because just
like this becomes a solved problem
gcp has a very similar offering
this is called vertex ai they keep
changing the name it looks like it's
about half the price of sagemaker which
i find very nice
and i create the same instance four
cores 15 gigs of ram and then it's in
jupyter lab once again
and then we're just copying and pasting
this example
and then finally in terms of getting
things installed so hopefully this ends
hopefully this is like hey if i can run
one contact command i can get everything
installed this rapids package includes
desk it includes number includes all of
this stuff you could also just pip
install them directly but it can get a
little bit tricky this is where i should
have prefaced this beginning this is
really where rapids as a package shines
it gives you cootie it gives you all of
the stuff all of it works
finally if you want to do this on your
clusters docker is a great tool for this
you don't have to learn docker uh they
will give you this docker command a
pre-built container image and then what
i did with coiled here just for complete
you know for completeness when i created
these clusters i specified
what uh image i wanted to use there's a
facility within coiled for doing this
that's a docker image but this also
works for other tools for deploying desk
and i'll talk about that here in a
second um but so basically for getting
set up locally uh
this is it's it's use rapids and it's
going to be very straightforward then
we've got a great question in the chat
which is like hey can i wait can i use
number jet can i use number with desk
and the answer is yes absolutely
so that will be my that was this should
be my
concluding example here
so i've got my
oh
let's just restart this
uh yes you can combine them and the
reason i spent more time on qdf than on
working with numba and i apologize if
that was if that led some folks
australia from my from my uh agenda
was the i was kind of blown away by just
the completeness with qdf how easy it is
to get started and how when you use that
you can scale this out very nicely
number when we're going to run on the
gpu is going to involve a slightly
different api than running on the cpu
and that was a change i don't know how
recently this change occurred but from a
previous version of this code that i'd
run with like number like 0.48 it didn't
involve this api change and i'll be
honest it kind of walked me in the head
so but yes our code will run here this
will this will work um
and let's
sorry i have to make sure i have the
right cluster
let's get that
existing
uh
cpu example v2
all right let's get our client object
and i i may not have enough time here to
show this but the short answer is yes it
can and so in this case i have that same
number jit that same code we've wrapped
our existing code with number and then
we can submit it to our das cluster and
here uh previously you just saw like das
qdf you just saw das dataframe it was a
pandas-like thing here we're using the
lower-level interface that i mentioned
at the very beginning when i introduced
ask this is das
futures interface it's very similar to
python 3's concurrent futures and so now
i can submit arbitrary tasks and tasks i
can submit each of these functions
and in so doing i can now start to see
linear speed up here so we can we can
take that compiled code we can send it
to the schedule we can send it across
our workers and we can see linear speed
ups across our dash cluster um so yes
this does work very very well and this
also works number is is absolutely
compatible with with cuda with running
on the gpus there's just a slight
adjustment in terms of setting some
initial variables that has me as again
as a very basic beginner type user
somebody who was walking into a server
room versus using an ssh client a little
bit stymied at the moment
um
to do okay
all right so let's wrap this let me wrap
this up with uh deployment options and
i'll jump back and show this from slides
uh just to keep this
a little bit cleaner
so in wrapping this up you can deploy
task a bunch of different ways
das can be installed manually there's
excellent documentation i have links to
all of this it's just a cli command
there is a tool for running desk on your
cloud provider aws azure gcp and a few
others this tool is called das cloud
provider it's open source you can go
ahead and use it you can also deploy
desk on kubernetes and so if you had a
cluster of machines you could now say
great if i've got a cluster of gpu
workers i can use to ask kubernetes i
could use that cloud provider i need to
use a
an image or two from rapids to make sure
i have my dependencies but that's your
pattern there are also commercial
offerings uh three particular coiled
where i work in sales
saturn cloud also offers they're very
much a competitor they offer das
clusters as a service you know
hassle-free dash clusters
and then in terms of the major cloud
offerings there isn't a aws or azure
desk offering yet but google
data proc which is oops i'm sorry google
dataproc which is their spark cluster as
a service it has a dat uses an open
source dash package called basque yarn
to deploy desk uh your mileage may vary
with that but it is an option obviously
i'm heavily biased towards coiled
because i work there
a quick recap on costs and then i think
we'll i'll wrap this up as i know i keep
saying i will so i'm running the initial
the client
you saw sagemaker you saw google cloud
you would see azure but i'm
getting some quota issues and it's just
a little too expensive i think for this
for for the budget i was trying to set
for this um so here are the costs
factoring in the clusters i got from
coiled this case 38 cents for the hour
of my gcp notebook and then 81 cents for
my gpu cluster and then similarly for
aws 75 cents for an hour of my sagemaker
notebook and 81 cents for my gpu cluster
about half the cost excuse me for the um
for the cpu cluster
so the nice thing here again however you
choose to deploy ephemeral dash clusters
you'll if you're running these in the
cloud we'd highly encourage you only run
them when you actually are executing
your code when you're thinking about
things you're sipping coffee when you're
hanging out and just mulling over your
problem use a much less expensive
client
oh and before uh before i'm going to
skip comparisons actually and say
the final bit of this that's i think
that's exciting is a relatively recent
python package
eric welch and james berbeau just
recently put out
and this is a tool called afar
so
if you don't want to use a gpu client if
you don't want to if you don't have a
gpu on your local machine if you don't
want to install rapids on your local
machine if you don't want to bother
setting up a sagemaker notebook a gcp
notebook or an azure ml compute instance
you actually can run all these things
from a local machine thanks to this new
package called afar this is really
really cool it's very new so it's still
from for me personally i still tend to
use one of these gpu clients to get to
make things easier but i all i have to
do now to have here back on my local
machine local host i can import afar
and with this little you know with
statement i can now apply
i can run remotely submit this code to
my das cluster we'll come back over you
can see this on the gpu example this
code is going to be executing here on my
gpu cluster and i'm doing this from a
local machine where i don't have it i
don't have a gpu on my macbook i don't
have cuda installed i don't have to
worry about those dependencies i can
work with a das cluster afar
so big thank you to eric big thank you
to james we'll be looking for more from
this package again i think you'll
probably still find it useful to have
some local gpu client it may even save
you money if you're only doing if you
have smaller data sets or if those
longer times are
are acceptable um but now you could say
okay hey i could use a remote cluster
from somebody like coiled or saturn
cloud or something else or desktop
provider and i could do i can work from
my local machine directly with that
cluster without having to set up this
intermediate client
okay
uh so there i will pause now i'll stop
sharing um i hope we're not too i'm 20
minutes over
my apologies um
there are a bunch of great tutorials on
desk on them yeah i i don't think there
are any other questions in the chat um
thank you all for for listening and uh
for for showing up
you